The buzzer sounds.
The teammates’ hands link and raise up in
victory.
The heads of the other team dip in defeat.
The orange basketball is flung up in celebration.
Young student-athletes dance around, releasing
a year’s worth of pent up stress due to
basketball and (in theory) school-work.
Another men’s basketball NCAA championship
has been won.
The winning team gathers, exchanging high-fives
and hugs, as ladders are brought out to the
court and positioned underneath the baskets.
With a pair of scissors in hand, each member
of the team, from the players to coaches to
the training staff, are given a chance to
climb the ladder and snip a tangible piece
of this memory for themselves.
By doing this, they are engaging in the tradition
known as the “cutting of the nets.”
The basketball net, the very same one that
had shot after shot swish through pushing
this team to victory, has now become a piece
of sports memorabilia.
This custom of “cutting the nets” began
where many other basketball traditions had
their beginnings — in the state of Indiana.
When asked by his Indiana high school yearbook
what he believed his future occupation would
be, Everett Case answered “basketball coach.”
And this was in 1919 — before the NCAA,
before the NBA, and before basketball held
the American sporting conscious like it does
today.
For an 18 year old high school graduate to
answer that question with an occupation that
was, well, not really an occupation at the
time, showed his undying passion for the game.
Upon graduation, Case attended the University
of Wisconsin-Green Bay.
Afterwards, he went to the University of Illinois
to study the finer points of the game under
the great Ralph Jones, considered by many
to be the father of Indiana high school basketball.
At the age of 22, Case was selected over 18
other applicants to become Frankfort High’s
basketball and track coach.
Within three years, Case had led the small
central Indiana high school to the state championship.
Over his 16 season tenure at Frankfort, Case’s
teams would win the state championship three
more times.
After each championship, Case would remind
his boys to always cherish the memory and,
perhaps, to take a little something that would
help them with that task.
Often, that little something were the basketball
nets.
In 1941, and at the age of 41, Everett Case
gave up being a high school basketball coach
to join the Navy.
It was said that Case, ever enthusiastic and
patriotic, joined in such a haste that he
left his desk at the school fully stocked
and didn’t retrieve his belongings until
he returned five years later.
While in the Navy, Case was commissioned as
a senior-grade lieutenant and trained in Chicago
and California.
But his real talents were coaching and organizing
young men to play basketball.
He was appointed the Navy’s assistant athletic
director and director of basketball.
After the war, Case returned to the state
of Indiana to retrieve his belongings from
his desk, but he did not stay long.
Upon leaving the Navy, he took his coaching
expertise south and became the head coach
at North Carolina State University.
Case had immediate success at NC State, leading
them to the 1946 Southern Conference title.
In 1947, NC State again won the conference
title.
Upon victory, Everett Case, excited, proud,
and wanting to cherish the memory, harked
back to his days at Frankfort High in Indiana.
Remembering his players snipping the net,
he asked arena workers for a ladder.
Unfortunately, there was no ladder to be found.
Case, undeterred, had his players hoist him
up on their shoulders for him to grab his
twine memento.
The Hoosier tradition had found its way to
the national stage.
Case would go on to become a coaching legend,
establishing NC State as a college basketball
powerhouse.
They would win four more Southern Conference
titles before moving to the Atlantic Coast
Conference (the ACC) and winning four more.
He was named the ACC Coach of the Year three
times.
Case is credited in turning North Carolina,
always football country, into a basketball-crazed
state (for evidence, watch a Duke or UNC basketball
game).
He popularized the postseason tournament,
convincing the ACC to put on their conference
tournament in his home arena and the NCAA
to award the winner of the conference tournament
automatic entrance into the NCAA championship
tournament.
He is still the winningest coach in NC State
history and was enshrined into the Basketball
Hall of Fame in 1982.
In 1964, Case was diagnosed with multiple
melanoma, a cancer of plasma cells.
The disease is incredibly painful as it slowly
eats away at the bone marrow in one’s body.
Case had to retire only two games into the
season.
During that year’s ACC tournament, Case
was not on the sideline, but rather sat courtside
and confided to a wheelchair.
He watched as his NC State Wolfpack upset
the top-ranked – and interstate rival – Duke
Blue Devils.
When the final buzzer sounded, the players
walked over to Case and helped him out of
his wheelchair.
They placed their beloved coach on their shoulders
and watched as Case snipped his final net.
Eighteen months later, Everett Case would
pass away, but the tradition of preserving
lifelong college basketball memories with
a snipe of twine still persists to
this day.